[Music]
i know this may come as a
shock to many of you but as of today
i will be streaming exclusively on mixer
i'm making moves
as of the 29th of october we will be
streaming exclusively on mixer
but i just knew 100 like this is
this is it mixer dropped a surprise
announcement by saying
it's shutting down they're giving up i
feel betrayed
i've given everything i couldn't have
given more because they didn't have any
idea
i had so many so many dreams for the
future for the first time
because i've been depressed for so long
the people behind mixer once had really
high hopes for the platform
we've seen phenomenal growth and success
of the platform
we've launched a cross-platform service
we have all kinds of innovative features
and functionality within the space
it all started in 2016 when microsoft
picked up a promising streaming startup
called
beam they renamed it mixer and stuffed
it full of features that were supposed
to make it
better than twitch the website was very
how could i say it smooth compared to
twitch
that's which is uh what was a bit
scuffed like
for what it was whereas mixer just
everything just seemed more in a word
futuristic
but all the innovations that mixer
brought to the table didn't really
matter
twitch was the unrivaled king of
streaming
twitch has the highest number of viewed
hours of any live streaming platform
by far but being so huge comes with its
own set of problems
for example twitch is notorious for
toxicity
okay boxy broccoli had ass
typing first thing hey honey haha play
with me i'll carry you i'm immortal
what are you delusional i swear to god
did i reject you and you're saying ah
that's why this base game is bigger than
our gameplay
mixer offered a chance for people who
were intimidated by twitch's size
reputation and
yes toxicity to stream to an audience of
thousands without having to compete with
the established
big names on twitch the welcoming
community that was on
mixer at the time or should i say beam
at the time it was uh
it was a different platform than say
twitch or youtube or anything else was
at the time it was
almost like a family of outcasts that
didn't fit in anywhere else on
what was already considered an outcast
sort of thing but as
welcoming as mixer's community may have
been microsoft was really hoping for a
financial
success and in 2019 three years after
mixer launched
it wasn't really making a dent in
twitch's viewership
so microsoft busted out the big guns if
people weren't gonna pay attention to
mixer well
they were gonna force them to pay
attention by signing the biggest gamer
on the planet
first dove on mixer ever
we've got a little surprise for you
coming off that win
[Music]
congratulations on mixer we're all so
proud of you
this is so awesome that announcement was
the first in a series of huge signings
it's not hard to understand why these
big names sign these contracts
sure mixer had a lower viewership but
the money doesn't matter
all of a sudden these people were free
to do whatever they wanted
they had to stream sure but they could
play whatever they wanted they could
build their brand
they didn't have to grind day in and day
out chasing trends
and these signings kicked off a war for
top tier talent
the best part is that i'm not gonna make
it any harder for you because i've
officially resigned with twitch
i'm moving to facebook gaming check me
out there bye
so when are you leaving 100 thieves what
i'm not leaving 100 thieves
i'm joining youtube
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but if mixer was hoping that ninja and
shroud would bring their huge twitch
communities and
viewership with them they were sorely
disappointed
mixer needed us we may have needed
mixard to have a platform to stream on
and make our community
but they needed us in a way like they
they brought in streamers such as ninja
shroud and i loved
i do love ninja and shout out i've
watched ninja since halo days and
ewoks are lovely late oh she's a lovely
girl she's
awesome but
it just shows that you can't really pay
your way to success
while the big names did bring in big
numbers they just couldn't get the same
viewership they had on twitch
twitch is so deeply ingrained in the
gaming community that even people's
favorite streamer going over to mixer
couldn't convince them to stop
watching people on twitch man you guys
are my friends i know
how many viewers are across the board do
we have right now
i don't even know man probably i
probably like what 500.
[Music]
bro you i mean that's like all a mixer
right
mixer took a huge gamble and it wasn't
paying off but
what came next shocked everyone
one month they're giving us one month
out of nowhere mixer announced that they
were shutting down the platform was gone
for good
on july 22nd this is years of hard work
for everyone building a really safe
platform
that clearly didn't have the intentions
in the first place
they've hidden behind such a huge
[ __ ] cover
i'm disgusted in microsoft i'm disgusted
i'm mixing
mixers partners the people who try to
make a career out of streaming on mixer
were offered a chance to switch over to
facebook gaming and keep their partner
status there but
most people weren't really excited about
that offer
it was like it was literally like a
punch in her face it was
literally getting dumped by a text it
was
absolutely awful it was a rubbish
feeling
i think the problem that everybody had
wasn't that mixer is shutting down
it was the way they shut it down um we
always knew that that was one of the
appeals of going to mixer
was there was opportunity there but when
there's opportunity there's always risk
and you've just got to weigh those up
and the people that streamed there
weighed those risks up we knew it was a
risk
we just expected to be treated better
and as more details about the sudden
shutdown came out
it was clear that things had been a mess
at mixer for a
long time streamers weren't the only
people blindsided by mixer's shutdown
a lot of the staff had no idea that it
was closing either
it's not like all of mixer knew this was
going to happen
it was only a very select few and most
of the staff found out
when we found out and from what i've
been told
from other people is that the staff got
an email 15 minutes before the tweet
went out
so like everybody was kind of hit by
this
for huge streamers like ninja and shroud
mixer shutting down meant that they
could basically do whatever they wanted
they got their money and their freedom
but for smaller streamers the people who
painstakingly built communities and
even careers out of their mixer channels
the news was devastating
but when you've put two years of your
life
believing in the platform that was so
different
[Music]
i fully believed in mixer i sat there
and said do you know what no matter what
i know there's issues
but it's different it's community it's
it had it really had such a different
feel to it
it's hot oh it's hard it's hard
oh it is
a very emotional roller coaster today
i have given everything
every dollar i have every amount of
energy i have
into this platform because i believed in
it the offer to move to facebook is
meaningless for most mixer streamers
they basically have to start from
scratch
i'm now in this point of being someone
that has built a career built a
community
having to decide do i have to rebrand
will twitch give me the name that's on a
non-active account will they not
do i have to completely change and
uproot everything and then try to reach
out to my entire community like some of
my community are out
in afghanistan right now and they tune
in with the troops and
people like that so it's it's a it's a
life-threatening decision for many other
people as well i know a lot a lot of
partners and a lot of people
who are not partnered that are having
just these same issues
and it's up here it's upheavaled
everyone from the mixer platform
came at us all blind and um yeah
it's it's it's a hard time for a lot of
people faced with this impossible choice
most mixer streamers decided to start
over again on twitch
what happened immediately after mixer
announced that
people left in droves like mixer is
basically a ghost town now
and so you either got up and left or you
died there that's pretty much how it was
gonna go
i spoke to other streamers i spoke to
mods i spoke to friends
i spoke to everyone i could and everyone
was switching to twitch
but besides the obvious hurdles that
come with starting again on a new
platform
most mixer streamers felt like they were
losing something far more precious than
a paycheck
i might not have been here as long as
some of the partners but i've said
every stream has changed my life
it's really cute
you guys have been the best this has
been the best
honestly the best three years of my life
honestly i cannot express that enough
dude
when we look back on mixer in a few
years it'll be remembered for a lot of
things
it'll be remembered as the platform that
started the streaming wars that
legitimized a full-time career in
streaming because they proved that
he could come with a huge paycheck it'll
be remembered as a disaster of a
streaming platform
a service that spent however many
millions to secure big names
and then failed miserably but it will
also be remembered for abandoning the
people who needed it
most but as a whole i just feel like
what mixer was promised to be
was never actually true it was led to
feel like this big community where
everybody had an
impact and that we we all could help
grow a site that was different than
things that already existed
and now i realized that maybe that was
naive of me to believe
we can make all the jokes in the world
about ninja and shroud getting paid to
do nothing
but the fact of the matter is most mixer
streamers have been left to fend for
themselves
and now they have to find a new home one
that they can only hope
won't crumble down around them again
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you